Lucca Nate here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we're catching and
cooking squirrels yeah well welcome to
another episode of the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we are dealing
with the squirrel epidemic now if you
follow my channels you'll know that we
have had this battle before we had
squirrels that nibbled on my gas tank on
my boat they chewed several holes in my
garage we had to replace our garage door
and we did a catch alive I've trapped
video that helped deter them from
visiting our home for about a year or so
but they are back in force in causing
trouble and this time they've hit us
right where it hurts our pocketbooks the
squirrels have been crawling under the
hoods of our cars and chewing stuff we
had one chew up the fuel line on one of
my cars and the other one got into the
computer like wiring harness and they
chewed that up and destroyed it to the
tune of $3,000 so we we have spent a lot
of money on car repairs so squirrels are
scum and our homes now you may be saying
Luke don't hurt the squirrels you can
just trap them and relocate them that's
very very illegal and as I tell my
clients because I'm a criminal defense
attorney if you're gonna do illegal
things don't post videos about it on
YouTube so instead we are going to be
hunting some squirrels and we live in an
area where we can hunt squirrels on our
own property and we're gonna do that and
we're going to also cook them up and see
if we can't make some yummy squirrel
dishes but first we need to start
trapping some squirrels anything you
ready to eat it squirrel
[Music]
alright guys gonna make the trigger here
take this branch dust that off there
what's that off there okay there you go
something like that sharp in that side
all right here's a trigger you had a
flat little bit of stick like that put
it in like that okay
anything disrupts it pops off all right
guys that's right there is the squirrels
nest and where the culprits live and
we're gonna go ahead and set up our trap
right the base of the tree I got some
sixty pound monofilament here when you
use for my string
[Music]
pop that out yeah all right I got a
little piece of bread and I've mushed it
onto this stick okay put a little peanut
butter on it we're gonna shove it in the
bottom of this hole the stick is just to
make it so the squirrel has to work to
get it out he'll get it out of there
easy if he wants but I want them to move
around and bump into the trigger there
you go got a little noose right there
does it have to stay shut on its own
because the spring of the trap will
apply pressure to it so we just need to
get it in there
the critical part here is positioning
this loop he's got to stick his head
body in that loop oh no buddy I told you
stand back this will poke you in the eye
bud
I really don't want this flying up and
taking your eyeball out the squirrel has
to come from this direction or this trap
isn't going to work if he bumps this
part we comes from this side they'll set
the trap out without getting caught so
what we're going to do is we're going to
put a lot of junk right over here to
make this the obvious access point oh I
can't forever we got the trap all set up
it took a lot of finessing it's just a
real fidgety sort of thing you're
constantly adjusting the trigger and
tweaking this and that took like 3040
minutes but I don't have a lot of
practice at itself but little Nathan I
think misunderstood the assignment
because he brought this over for me for
when I travel squirrels yeah it's gonna
be a little different well guys that
squirrels snares been sitting in my
front yard for about three days and they
have not touched the bait at all
nobody's even gone near there absolutely
ignoring my snare so we gotta get rid of
some squirrels though so we're up in the
ante and I'm busting out this Benjamin
trail mp2 2.22 caliber pellet gun
hunting pellet gun and it shoots a lead
pellet about 900 feet per second it
shoots alloy ones about 1100 feet per
second and it will get the job done and
it's nice too because you know I'm I'm
in an area where I really don't want to
be shooting a 22 caliber gun around and
the law there's a lot of laws about
shooting firearms in this area but I can
hunt squirrels legally with the pellet
gun in my neighborhood so we're gonna go
ahead and do just that but first we're
going to decide in the gun make sure we
got it dialed in because one thing we
don't want to do is wing a squirrel
we're gonna shoot them we want to kill
it okay we got these Crossman domed
ultra Magnum point to two lead pellets
here and
we're gonna go see if we can hit our
target thank you very much sir okay
these guns are loads of fun but they're
not particularly accurate beyond 25
yards so I've got my target set at 25
and it's hard to get a grouping smaller
than that at 25 it's they're kind of all
over the place and there's a lot of
fliers so now it's time to go squirrel
hunting
careful don't him to bite you oh he is
fat okay yeah that is a big one well
that is a chunky squirrel I grew up in
Alaska and the squirrels up they are so
skinny and scrawny they're about 1/3 or
1/4 this size this thing is substantial
is like a small rabbit one squirrel down
two to go
but Tommy got a little bit cold so we're
gonna let him go inside warm up and I'm
gonna just sit here on the sunny side of
a tree trunk see what happens well Jacob
decided to come out and join us on our
squirrel hunt
[Music]
back there we go oh my gosh oh mama you
honest you like hand you take J Kobe it
was so fun hunting with you but it's
your nap time buddy and I'll come back
up in a little bit I forget doesn't got
in this world what are you doing well we
got two squirrels and it's getting a
little cold and dark so let's go and
clean our squirrels and get ready for
some squirrel dinner no we've got two
very fat gray squirrels and you need to
skin these things and clean them and get
cooking on them so first off let's get
the skin off all right guys we're going
to try to skin and gut these squirrels
and to start we're gonna get right in
here and go like that all the way
through that tail a little bit on either
side just like that okay let's put that
sucker down there
step on the floppy bit yeah
there you wanted to get it started it's
a lot easier
okay once you get the skin over his head
just kind of stick your fingers in his
elbow like that and then pull fingers
out and then get the skin off the skin
here just make a little incision so you
get a flappy bit of skin to grab a hold
up doesn't need to be much
oh and work the feet off yeah there we
go one fat healthy male squirrel skin
take the head off and get up in here try
not to cut up the guts have all the
reproductive organs off you do just go
ahead and grab the esophagus pull all
the way down get in the garbage let's go
ahead and quarter this thing up there we
go all right well we got the leftover
hides and I want to do something with
these as well but I'm gonna go take care
of dinner first so I'm just going to go
ahead and wrap these suckers up and keep
them cold until I'm ready to deal with
them
alright guys I got the squirrel meat all
cleaned and ready to cook and a lot of
people like to fry up squirrel or make
squirrel stew but we're gonna do
something a little bit weird we're gonna
make squirrely kabila pulao now camila
pulao is the national dish of
afghanistan it's a sweet and savory rice
dish with carrots and raisins and goat
meat and it is one of my absolute
favorite things in the world
it is delicious absolutely delicious and
I want to make squirrel Kabila pulao not
just because I'm a weird dude but
because it's designed to go with Gomi
Gomi it's a little bit tougher than a
lot of other meats and it makes it super
tender
and just tastes so good and so wild
meets likes Comey might work really well
and squirrely can be a bit below as well
so we're gonna give it a try and see
what happens and I have never done this
before
I've never made squirrel based kabylia
pulao before so this will be an
adventure
it'll be Appalachian Afghani fusion but
I'm going to show you how to make this
awesome dish and how to cook up the
squirrel and we're gonna have some fun
isn't that right Jacob all completely
pulao is is you've got rice carrots
onions raisins some seasonings and meat
it's basically the way you do it is you
cook the raisins and the carrots and
some oil then you take it out of the pot
you cook the onions and the meat
together you season them you add the
broth then you pull them out of the pot
and you know the rice to the broth and
then you cook the rice in the broth
mix it all back up together and simmer
it and that's Camilla pull out so let me
show you how it's done
[Music]
[Applause]
the Wrights is a little bit squished
together but if you use long grain rice
instead of eating green rice it'll be
more like it should but on that it
turned out pretty good you know the real
fun thing about doing these recipes
where you mix up different cultures is
it allows people from all over the world
to say that I suck at cooking some now
getting grandma it's gonna get on the
internet just like you suck all right
well let's try to squirrel beds out okay
let's see how it's cooking that's really
soft it's actually pretty good
really soft a lot of wild game meats you
can get tough on me because you don't
have a lot of fat content that's as
tender it kind of reminds me of dark
meat chicken with a little bit of
sweetness to it lots of little bones and
tendons on it you know it's hard to find
a good solid piece of beat on them but
it's actually not bad it really does
taste like dark meat dark meat chicken
here maybe you got to try something I
didn't know you can meet that I gave you
a clean bite then you messed with that
look if we get this all the little tiny
bite with all that other stuff on there
it's good
I don't tend to like wild meat I'm gonna
edit this down right I have to is taking
the whole length of the video maybe in
Reverse I can do this focus on the
reason hates girl there was only trace
about the squirrel I would take a lab
tape they should three months to
determine that well it's been a long day
and I'm gonna turn off the camera here
and eat my food and then I'm going to go
and prepare the Heinz well got my two
little squirrel pelts in here and I want
to do something kind of fun with them so
I'm gonna flesh them out get them
preserved up and I'll show you what I'm
doing all right let's see here
getting close getting close yeah this is
kind of squishy Dell watch this what
we're gonna do you have cakes
huh salt does the salt the salt soaks up
the moisture and the gooey stuff and the
gooey stuff and the gooey stuffs what
makes it smell so if we get rid of the
gooey stuff then it won't smell
all right we'll just let that salt sit
for a couple days
dissolve all that little membrane and
dry out the hide then we'll go from
there
all right we've had the salt on the
squirrel skin for about a week now and
so let's go ahead and take it off the
board see how it's doing that's what it
looks like there's a few spots here and
there where I'm thinking maybe a little
bit more salt would do but this will be
good enough for this part I'm just gonna
use this part for today
all those feelings
[Music]
all right there we go
a little keychain squirrel tail went
ahead and put a little flip on it that
isn't that nice yeah we got this one too
which one do you want Tommy it's got a
little coat hanger so you can go oh and
you can actually bend it like that Oh or
you can make it like that clip it on
there there you go
keychain collection you have a lot of
key shades look at that all right you
ready to go to school buddy
all right go for it if you liked this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boy's youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]